- One could easily spend
a lot of time introducing
Professor Jim Robinson,
but I won't do that.
I'll just do a short introduction.
So we're very happy to have Jim,
who's an economist and
a political scientist.
And currently the Pearson Professor
of Global Conflict Studies
as the University Professor
at the University of Chicago.
Throughout his life has
done very interesting work
that involves a combination
of modeling and field work.
And today we'll hear about
Bolivia and in the past,
I've heard about other
places in south America,
actually also the Democratic
Republic of the Congo
and from what I gathered
from our conversation,
we might hear about Nigeria soon as well.
So I'm looking forward to that too.
Jim, thanks very much for joining us,
and we're in a hybrid mode,
so there are some people in the room
and then some of us on Zoom.
- Okay, yes great.
Thank you very much for inviting me.
I'm very sorry, not to be there.
I did my PhD at Yale,
so I must say have a lot of friends there
and I always like going back to New Haven.
It does remind me of some times,
perhaps I'd rather forget.
Okay, so you will hear about Nigeria,
but that's far off.
So let me share my screen.
There we go.
All right, thank you very much.
So I'm gonna talk about Bolivia indeed,
but I'm going to start by putting the data
and the specific research
in a bigger context
of comparative development
of Latin America
that I have worked on for many years
and the "Return of Pachamama",
you'll see where Pachamama comes in.
Pachamama is the earth mother,
kinda very powerful, important deity
for the Andean indigenous people.
And this is a joint
project with Carlos Molina.
Carlos is a PhD student in the
economics department in MIT,
and Selaya Pablo is a professor at
the Economics Department at the
University of Copenhagen in Denmark.
Let me talk about the big picture
and then I'll get into the little picture.
Here's a quote from one of the founders
of the MAS political party in Bolivia.
He's talking about coca and
its relationship to Pachamama.
So when you pray to
Pachamama, you offer coca
and other things and gifts
and sacrifices, okay?
So the way we're thinking
about this project is,
there's been an enormous
amount of research.
I, myself have worked on this a lot,
kinda inspire with deep roots.
I think the most obvious source
of renewed excitement in this question,
this comparative
development of the Americas,
is this famous paper by
Angerman Sokolov in 1997.
I must have read that paper 30 times.
When I found it originally,
it blew my mind.
It's a economic history, long run,
comparative development of the Americas,
emphasizing how colonialism
created these very different
societies in North America,
from South America.
And that explains very different
patterns of inequality,
social mobility, long run development.
Since they wrote there's being
some much more micro-work,
trying to dig into the nature
of Latin American institutions
and Latin American states and societies,
the sorts of things that
Angerman Sokolov talked about,
I think most famously Melissa Dell's
2010 paper on the Mit'a in Potosi,
where she examined in some
sense, the most famous
extractive institution
of the colonial period,
the Potosi, Mit'a.
She looked at the catchment area,
the boundaries of the
catchment area of the Mit'a,
which has this huge labor draft
of the minds in Potosi in Bolivia.
And she found that, if you compare places
just inside the Mit'a to
just outside the Mit'a,
places inside the Mit'a
had consumption levels,
which were a third less,
they had more child stunting
and she tells a brilliant story about how,
the Mit'a cast this long shadow over.
You'll see by the end of my
talk, why I'm emphasizing this.
Cast this long shadow
over economic development
in Peru and Bolivia.
But I guess our starting point,
and this is something that
I've come to understand
from working a lot in Colombia,
and working a lot in
rural Colombia is that,
colonial states were
very patchwork things.
They controlled large
areas of Latin America
in a very, very uneven way.
They were indirectly ruled by caciques,
by indigenous leaders in the
post-independence people,
by what's called Caudillos
in the historical literature.
And even during the colonial period,
they are separated into,
the Republic for Spaniards
and Republica De Indios.
So indigenous people were left separate,
self-governing and-
- Sorry to interrupt.
I'm worried that the slides
might be moving on your screen,
but not on the Zoom screen.
We still have just the title slide on the-
- No, no, no.
- Can you see anything now?
- So we can only see the title slide.
I think your computer
might be treating as...
Oh, there.
- Let me try again.
Shall I try and share again?
- Sure.
So the starting point for
this paper is, it's right.
The story about extractive
institutions in Latin America,
exploitation of indigenous
people, creation of inequality.
But I want to say it's very uneven.
And what we're trying to do in this paper,
I think is to dig into the
unevenness of the state
and the control and the span of the state,
and illustrate that this has
interesting possibilities.
It's not all negative, it
has positive possibilities.
And we think that's the story in Bolivia.
I changed the slide, can you see that?
So large parts of colonial Latin America,
and post-colonial Latin America,
were organized, you could say,
in this Republica De Indios,
where many of the indigenous
institutions persisted.
Much of the cohesion of
indigenous society persisted.
And the word that we
like is, moral economy.
This is a phrase that E.P. Thompson,
the British historian applied
to thinking about 18th century
British society, the moral economy,
the set of rules and norms
and practices that were really
outside of the colonial state and outside
of the post-colonial state.
And as James Scott argued
in his famous book,
"The Moral Economy of The Peasant",
when these moral economies are
challenged, they can react.
I'm gonna give one Colombian example.
Usually I talk far too
much about Colombia,
but one Colombian example,
which I always like,
just to illustrate this is,
Columbia is famous for being at one point,
the drug, the kidnapping, the
murder capital of the world.
And in the story of Latin American
deep inequality and development divergence
that emanates Angerman Sokolov,
there's a lot of emphasis on
elites and I think rightly so.
But I think what you
have to recognize is that
the hegemony of elites
has perhaps overemphasized
in a lot of this research,
including in my own research,
because in Columbia, it
wasn't Colombian elites
that wanted to turn the
country into the drug running,
homicide and kidnapping
capital of the world.
They just couldn't stop it.
Why couldn't they stop it?
Because they didn't control
large parts of Columbia.
There were large vacant spaces, vacuums,
where other elites could emerge
and other political projects
could emerge and that's an
interesting and positive thing.
At least we'll try to argue,
maybe not in the Colombian case.
Now here's an example of
not being able to control
half of Columbia, here's
three paramilitary warlords,
you could say, Ernesto Baez on the left,
Salvatore Mancuso in the middle,
and Ramon Isaza on the
right, what are they doing?
They're in Congress with suits on,
negotiating with the politicians.
So you don't control the periphery.
You negotiate with it.
And that's a different image, I think,
from a lot of this work
emphasizing very hegemonic elites.
So in this project, what we're going to do
is study what we think of as the violation
of the moral economy in rural Bolivia.
So this moral economy, deeply
rooted in the pre-Andean past
reproducing itself through
the colonial period,
through the post-colonial
period, in some sense,
to quote C.L.R. James, his
book on the Haitian revolution,
"It was a volcano waiting to go off!"
He uses this metaphor
that the French in Haiti,
were sleeping on the
edge of Vesuvius, okay?
It was sitting there, the
volcano was waiting to go off.
It didn't go off for hundreds of years,
but then it did go off.
And I think that's the way
we want you to think about
what's happened in Bolivia
in the last 20 years.
The volcano went off and
there's been a tectonic change
in the nature of politics and society.
And so we're gonna look at
that Bolivian experience,
but I want you to think more broadly that,
perhaps we haven't
conceptualized properly,
the nature of the state in Latin America,
very uneven control of
much of its territory,
and the possibilities that perhaps that
allows for that we haven't
grasped, including possibilities,
dramatic change, which is
what we've seen in Bolivia.
So what set off the volcano in Bolivia?
Well, our argument is it's basically,
the eradication of coca.
Remember you have to use
coca to honor Pachamama.
In 1997, Hugo Banzer,
who was the president,
struck a deal with the
United States aiming at,
I say sometimes, or we
say sometimes, zero coca.
The reason I we say sometimes
is that it's a little uneven.
If you look at all the documents,
it's a little uneven, what was going on,
and different documents
say different things,
but the basic thrust of
it seems to have been
President Banzer agreed to eliminate coca.
So what we're gonna look at in the data is
the consequence of this coca eradication
for politics in Bolivia
and the social consequences
that that has had, okay?
But I think to grasp,
why we're looking at coca
and the political consequences,
the attempt to eradicate coca,
if you're a Colombian, then
you say eradicate coca,
you think of helicopters
and planes spraying,
but this is how they do it
in Bolivia with a machete.
So just to give you the picture.
And here's just some sense,
the paper in the nutshell
as we're gonna get much
more into different things.
Here is the drug eradication
money on the left-hand axis,
flowing from the United
States that ramps up with this
Plan Dignidad, ironically
named the Plan Dignidad.
The bands are signs with
the U.S. government.
So there's a huge ramping
up of counter narcotics aid,
here's the voucher of
the MAS political party.
I'll talk a little bit about MAS.
Origins of MAS are very complicated.
It was organized by the cocaleros,
by these coca farmers
in the Chapare Valley,
in the east of Bolivia, but
there's many other groups
involved in it to start
with leftist groups,
women's groups, indigenous groups.
So let me not get into
the detailed history.
You could say this United Left Party,
Evo Morales was involved with
was anticipated a little bit.
The first time MAS really
runs as a party is in 1999.
And then you can see the
vote share rocket stop,
and Morales wins the
presidential election in 2005.
Then of course, he abandons
the counter narcotics policy,
through aid with with us away.
So what we're gonna be
mostly interested in,
is this period here of the impact
of this counter narcotics program,
on political support from us.
And then what were the
consequences, which came...
Some of the consequences
as a result of this
capture of the state,
which happens in 2005.
Anyone who's been in
Bolivia, in rural Bolivia
will know this already,
but as an Englishman,
to give you an analogy, an English analogy
of what would it be like?
What's the analogy in England
of banning coca in Bolivia?
It would be like banning beer.
If you ban beer and
close down all the pubs,
what would English people do?
I guess that's a bit trivial, really,
because coca is just
much more deeply embedded
in the culture and the religious
and the worldview of Andean people.
So here's Alan Kolata,
who's a colleague of mine
at the university of Chicago.
who's a very important scholar
of this part of the world,
and of indigenous society,
talking about the most important
institutionalized nation
of indigenous society
amongst the Aymara people in Bolivia.
So of course, Bolivia is very complicated.
It's very heterogeneous, ethnically.
In the Andean area, the
largest number of people
are Aymara or Quechua.
So the Ayllu is the name for a
local local Aymara community.
So here he's just describing
what the Ayllu is.
Principles of common identity.
Let me move this thing so
I could read it for you.
Principles are common identity,
mobilized around and
deeply sedimented through
interpersonal intimacy
drive from shared history,
shared labor, shared meals,
shared worship of a common ancestor.
So there's an enormous amount
of cooperative behavior,
very communal, many very famous reciprocal
institutions of labor sharing,
collective activity for
building houses, cooking,
providing public goods and in fact,
you have one of the most
famous scholars of this,
Enrique Mayer in the
Anthropology Department at Yale.
So you're in a great place,
if you want to learn more about this.
The Ayllu and the Marka
is the analogous Quechua institution,
is the main way that indigenous
society is organized.
And I think most of the scholars of this
see this as very historical.
So this is part, you
could say of, this story
I was telling you the
Republican De Indios.
This immense persistence of this
rural organization of indigenous people,
and many of the practices
and beliefs over time.
And I want to say that,
this is very connected with coca.
So Catherine Allen,
who's an anthropologist
at George Washington
University has written
a lot about this, about
how, it's one thing to say,
there's labor reciprocity.
You help me, I help you,
but I don't do anything without,
and I don't ask anything from you without
offering coca with what they call kintu.
I have to offer you three coca leaves.
If you worked in west
Africa, it's like cola,
cola and palm wine.
If you want to do anything
or talk to someone
or meet someone, you break
cola and you have palm wine,
so here it's coca and
cane liquor nowadays,
that's not very historic.
I guess, chicha or something
would have been more historic,
but cane liquor is more
practical perhaps nowadays.
And I won't go into this agenda.
I'm just throwing it out there,
I'm not gonna read it just to say,
coca is just cements.
Everything is coca, people
exchanging coca, giving coca.
It's just absolutely
central to people's lives.
So I think when you understand that,
you see how crazy this trying
to abolish coca and make coke,
not just eradicate coca,
but make coca illegal,
this is just an enormous
violation of this moral economy.
That's the argument here.
Here's Pablo doing kintu,
when we were doing fieldwork last year.
This is the sort of thing
where, when you do field work,
this just really hits you,
and it brings home how central
is says to people's lives
and the way they think about things.
So I regret that that superficial analogy
to Englishmen drinking beer.
This is much more serious
and important than that.
Okay.
There's a very rich
secondary literature about
the rise of the MAS and the
organization of the MAS,
and the connection between
the MAS and the Ayllu
and these indigenous organizations.
So there's very interesting
work by Bolivian scholars
looking at that, so let
me not dwell on that.
But many leaders of the MAS,
many representatives of the
MAS in national institutions
or local institutions,
they have roots in the
Ayllu and the Marka.
They've served in executive positions.
They have very interesting
political institutions,
the Ayllu and the Marka.
They rotate every year.
Everyone takes it in turn
to do different positions
within the hierarchy,
different executive positions.
And it's a very democratic,
republican type of thing,
but I won't go into that.
So just to say, it's,
well-documented, this connection
between these indigenous
institutions and the mass.
Just to anticipate the
results and I'll talk about
what data we use to talk about this.
What I'm gonna show you to start with.
Remember that picture,
there's this ramping up
of counter narcotics aid,
and there's this ramping
up of the mass vote share.
What I'm going to show
you to start with is that,
there's a very close
connection between coca,
not actual coca, but coca suitability
and the MAS vote share.
So in places that are suitable for coca,
I'll explain how we
measure that in a minute,
the MAS vote share goes up differentially,
when Plan Dignidad comes into operation.
So empirically, the way
to think about this is,
we're gonna take Plan Dignidad
as a aggregate shock affecting Bolivia.
And then we're gonna look
at how that interacts
with the old coca suitability.
Much more interesting is,
we have a very detailed information
on where these Ayllus are in Bolivia.
So more broadly where indigenous land is.
So indigenous people
have been able to claim
rights to their traditional
lands in Bolivia.
And so we have a map of that.
So we can actually look not
just a coca suitability,
but something much more
interesting, which is,
do we see a differential
increase in the vote share
of the MAS when Plan Dignidad comes in,
in places where there are the Ayllu.
And the answer is yes, and
none of this is confounded
by the development effect.
So you might think, oh,
everyone's growing coca.
When Plan Dignidad comes in,
not a big negative shock.
So of course, there's a political reaction
to a negative economic shock.
None of what I'm saying
is confounded by that.
So we can control for that.
And the other thing, which is fascinating,
for someone who works a lot in Africa,
is that this doesn't seem to
be about ethnicity either.
The ethnic political geography of Bolivia
is extremely complicated
as I talked about earlier.
None of this is confounded by...
It's not being driven
by ethnicity in any way.
I'll tell you how we
control for that, okay?
So there's a significant
differential impact
of this Plan Dignidad
on the MAS vote share,
in places which are coca suitable,
and more interesting where the Ayllu is.
So we can look at that
in a panel data setting,
but also because we have this map,
we can actually do or show
the regression discontinuity
results that we can look at
the boundary of the Ayllu,
and what I'm gonna show you is that
there's large jumps in the MAS vote share.
When I look at just inside
the Ayllu boundary and just outside.
So we have a couple of
ways of identifying,
of trying to identify the
causal effect of this.
And then what are the
consequences of that?
So that's just trying
to show there's this,
coca that violates this moral economy,
and then there's a massive
organization society,
which elites can't stop, they can't stop,
and they capture the state.
What happens when they capture the state?
And we're gonna look at two strategies.
One is social mobility
of indigenous people
using data from the Latinobarometro.
There's a significant increase
in actual and expected
rates of social mobility
for indigenous people,
when the MAS come to power.
And I think most interesting
is we managed to collect
6 million birth records.
So we actually have the names
that people give their children.
And what we can show is that
there's an enormous increase.
This is 75% increase in
the incidence of people
giving their children indigenous names.
So we want to say, we call that
the empowerment effect that
indigenous people, instead
of giving their children
Spanish names, and now are far more likely
to be giving them indigenous names.
So towards that, reflects
the fact that this political
change is really creating
a inclusive social change,
which I think anyone who goes to Bolivia,
it hits you in the face
if you're in El Alto
or even in La Paz, spreading into La Paz.
So that, we're gonna document
that in a couple of ways.
It's difficult to manage
questions and comments
in a seminar like this.
I don't know, Mushfiq, if you have
what you think is optimal, I could stop,
so that people ask questions,
or I could just plow ahead
and finish, before the end?
- Actually, if there
are good places to pause
and give people 20 seconds,
like you're doing right now,
that's great, but that
it's also not a regular
econ seminar in the sense that
there's people from all
different disciplines where
they're used to waiting till the end.
As long as there no too
many questions right now,
if you can wait until
the end, that's fine too.
- So I'm gonna talk a little
bit about the data now,
and I'll talk about...
I'll try to leave at least
20 minutes at the end
for people to ask questions.
Is that good?
Okay, all right.
So let me just plow on
and talk about the data.
To start the talk, the main
outcome variable is going to be
votes for the MAS, where we can either do
total number of votes or vote
share, it doesn't matter.
And we have this data in
a very disaggregated form.
So we have voting table data.
So we have the data at the
individual voting tables.
We haven't been able to
get that for all elections,
but we've been able to get
it for these elections here.
So 1999, 2004, 2005, 2009, 2010.
In the regressions, I'm going to show you,
we're going to use total number of votes
for the MAS at the voting table.
So what does that look like?
That's what all the voting
tables look like in Bolivia.
So it's very desegregated
and we're gonna situate
the voting table in a pixel.
That's 10 by 10 kilometer square,
and we're gonna measure
different things in that square,
such as, coca suitability,
such as presence of the Ayllu.
I showed you the aggregate MAS vote share,
just to give you a sense of
how that changes over time,
you can see, in 1999, when
they first really run as a...
This is the Chapare Valley,
where the cocaleros first got organized.
So the MAS vote ramps up
in this part of Cochabamba
in the department.
And then, after that,
this is when 2005, when Evo
wins the presidential election,
you can see it's much more
widespread, but darker red means,
had more vote share between 50 and 100%.
So this is very much in the Altiplano.
Coca suitability is using
data that people use a lot
to measure different types of
crop suitability in economics.
It's very popular nowadays.
The FAO have this database and for coca,
it gives what they call
optimal or absolute conditions,
like for temperature, rainfall,
elevation slope, et cetera.
So that gives you a interval.
So for example, for temperature,
the optimal temperature
for growing coca would be
18 to 20 degrees
centigrade, but absolutely,
it's like a bigger window.
There's a bigger interval of temperatures.
So what we do is we just
take that data and we focus
on the absolute, it doesn't matter.
So far, this seems to be robust
to doing it with optimal.
And we just basically say,
if you take a five kilometer
by five kilometer grid cell,
if you're in the interval for temperature,
rainfall, elevation, slope,
et cetera, then that's a one.
So that five by five kilometer grid cell
is good for growing coca
and then we average it
up to 10 by 10, which is what we're using.
10 by 10 kilometer pixel, or grid cell
around the polling station.
This is what it looks like
so the darker here is,
the most suitable for growing coca.
Up again, tends to be not
completely in Altiplano,
it has to be down a little bit warmer,
the Chapare or the Yungas is down.
So it's too cold up in
El Alto to grow coca.
You have to be down a bit, but of course,
this large area along the
Eastern side of the Sierra here
which is highly suitable
for growing coca, okay?
So we have this stage
from the U.S. government.
On the counter-narcotics
aid, that's very standard.
I showed you what that looks
like just on that chart before.
So I won't talk about
that in too much detail.
And we have this wonderful map.
Here it is of...
As I said, the Ayllu is
the Aymara word for this,
but more broadly, communal land.
So there's a bit of slip.
I'm being a little bit naughty here,
but just to clarify
what we're going after,
because for example, down
here, if you can see my cursor,
this would be Guarani people.
This is not Aymara or Quechua people,
living down here on the
board with Paraguay.
So what I'm gonna show you today is,
we're gonna use all of
this, but you can see that.
So we can map this onto
this 10 by 10 grid cells.
But we can also do this regression,
discontinuity design, I guess,
which probably is more convincing as a way
of trying to identify the causal effect
of the impact of this Plan Dignidad
on the vote share of the
MAS and we're gonna control,
I don't want to talk too
much about development.
We want to say,
this is not really a
story about developments.
It's not that, you're growing coca,
they eliminate coca crops.
They come with a machete,
they cut it down.
That's a huge negative shock.
So of course, you vote
against the government.
But what I'm gonna show you actually,
and this is very nice in
the regression discontinuity
results is that, even in places
which are completely unsuitable for coca,
you have this very
significant treatment effect
of being in the Ayllu.
So people who are clearly not involved
up in the Altiplano, who are
clearly not growing coca,
they also vote massively in favor of MAS
when this plan comes in, why?
Because this is just the
front to their society.
So this is mostly trying to
control for developmental
nightlight, it's just
trying to really show you,
that's not a confounder here because
if you know this literature,
then you might think,
well, okay.
So and then there's the usual stuff,
latitude interacted with time dummies.
So I'm not going to go into that.
Let me talk about that
when I come to talk about social mobility.
So the first part that the data is just
using a very canonical panel data model.
So this is why IT is going
to be total number of votes
for MAS at polling station I in T,
and T are these waves of
elections that we have,
and then there's polling
station fixed effects
as time effects and then
we have DT is this total,
this is it's aggregate shock.
It's this total amount of
us drug eradication aid.
Aid in inverted commas,
I guess you could see.
CI is this index of coca suitability,
in the pixel around a polling station I,
and AI is gonna be in
these first regressions,
the proportion of land in
that pixel, which is held by
the Ayllu or indigenous communities.
So we want to see if there's
differential effects,
and then we can also look at
the triple interaction here.
So here's the results which
are most interesting, I think.
So let me jump to the results
that are most interesting.
So what do we find here?
We find a significant positive
effect of coca suitability
on number of votes for
MAS on the left hand side.
So we find that very robust.
Down here, there's all sorts
of different co-variants
we can play with and I guess
what I want to say here,
is that when you control
for nighttime lights,
I mean, you could say this
would be a bad control
in the Angrist and Pesky sense.
But anyway, I think in this context,
it's interesting to look at
whether that's the channel,
and that does nothing to the coefficients
that we're interested in.
You see this positive significance effect
for coca suitability and
also for community land
and the triple...
So just to emphasize here,
these coefficients are the
coefficients on the interaction
between this aggregate U.S drug aid,
and coca suitability, and
the proportion of Ayllu
community land within that grid cell.
So that's like a double interaction.
So this is like the
triple interaction, but,
we never find that to be significant.
So yeah, coca suitability matters.
Why does coca suitability matter?
I think the way we're thinking about that
is that that's picking
up in some sense that,
the location of this coca culture.
But of course the presence of the Ayllu
or community land for us
is much more interesting
'cause that's really showing,
where this institutionalized
indigenous society is.
Irrespective of coca suitability,
you find this positive,
significant effect on
the MAS vote share when Plan
Dignidad comes into operation.
And if you look at the
quantitative effects of this,
you see that, one standard like so.
Just to think about what
the Plan Dignidad did,
it increased U.S counter
drug money by about 2.3
standard deviations at its maximum.
And what we find for example
with the Ayllu is that,
when that comes in, a
one standard deviation
in U.S counter-drug aid
leads to a 10% increase
in the number of votes for MAS.
So this is quantitatively, very large.
That's what I want to show.
So given the increase
in U.S counter-drug aid,
the net effect of these two
forces here, i's very big.
Quantitatively, very big.
Yes.
- Jim, Orazio here.
I have a clarification question.
In your regression, do you have the...
'Cause you didn't show them in the table,
the direct effect of
coca stability and Ayllu,
without the interaction
with the Plan Dignidad?
- That's absorbed in the
fixed effects, isn't it?
Time-invariant, right?
- Okay.
- Yeah, so it's absorbed
in the fixed effect.
And I want to say, this
is not a simple story
of the rise of ethnic politics either.
So what we do is we
took the ethnologue map,
which has basically very
detailed information,
on the presence of different
ethnolinguistic groups,
really coded from language,
that's my understanding.
But we can map that onto
the 10 by 10 grid cell.
And so we can control for
the presence of different
ethnicities, Aymara,
Quechua, Guarani or whatever.
Again, that's the time invariant thing,
but interactive with time dummies.
This is not confounded by
the rise of Aymara politics
or the rise of Quechua politics.
And in fact, these institutions really
go across ethnic groups.
Especially Quechua and
Aymara, in a fascinating way.
So I could get into that in
more detail, but I think that's
probably not emphasized
enough at the moment.
You might think, oh,
it's indigenous people
have finally got mobilized,
so this is the rise of
ethnic politics or something,
but that's not the story we want to say.
We want to say this is
about this violation
of this moral economy.
All right, so now we can do this.
So that's the very straightforward
panel data approach to this.
We could do something a
little bit more sophisticated
since we have the map,
which is, we can narrow in
on the boundaries of these Ayllu
and try to compare places
just inside the Ayllu,
to just outside the Ayllu.
The analogous econometric model,
that seems closest to what we estimated
in the panel data model, is as follows.
So think of AI, as just being the distance
of the particular polling.
So now, again, we're thinking
about the polling stations,
because why YIT is, again, gonna be
the votes of the MAS party,
So we're gonna AI, like
the running variable,
is the distance from the polling station
to the boundary, if you like.
And then this is a very similar expression
to what we had before,
but just introducing
this regression discontinuity type model.
But think of the variables, the same DT
as the aggregate counter-drug aids,
CI is your coca suitability
and AI is the Ayllu.
Coca suitability goes
into the background here.
We're really focusing on
that map and thinking about,
what can we say at the
boundary of the Ayllu?
Do we see significant
jumps in the vote share
for MAS at the boundary?
And the answer to that is yes.
So here's a nice picture.
So imagine I narrow into two places
that are not coca suitable.
So forget about coca.
Well, don't forget about Coca,
but forget about growing coca.
And here's the boundary, and
this is the MAS vote share
when I go from being outside the Ayllu
to being inside the Ayllu.
So what we find is a significant
jump in the MAS vote share,
if the polling station
is inside the Ayllu.
So what's nice about these
results, if I show you the table,
is that the estimated
coefficients are extremely similar
to the basic panel data regressions.
We tried to do this in
a way which makes it
as comparable as possible,
'cause there's a lot of
robustness exercises here,
in terms of how you specify
the running variable.
This is the full sample.
This is what I showed you before.
Obviously you lose a
lot of the observations.
Now we're zooming in on
the boundaries of the map.
The boundaries of the Ayllu,
comparing polling stations
just inside, just
outside, we're gonna lose
a lot of polling stations
that are not close
or not anywhere near to these boundaries,
but the pattern here is very similar.
We don't find the triple
interaction to be...
I don't know why we even
have that there, really.
We thought it was
interesting at some point.
There's all this path
dependence in papers.
So here's the thing I
want to really emphasize,
which is this interaction between
the counter-narcotics and the Ayllu.
So that pattern is very similar.
These results are very similar.
They're just dropping
a lot of observations,
but they're zooming in
on, places where we think,
there's more identification
and we find something
very similar and it's very
robust to messing about with
different specifications
of the running variable,
different bandwidths and things like that,
With all the usual trade-offs.
So let me talk a little bit
about the consequences then,
and then I'll shut up.
We look at two things and we
could look at more things,
and I think the second
thing is more interesting.
So let me go first over this.
The first thing we look at
is just social mobility.
So how do we look at that?
Well, Latinobarometro
asks questions about...
It asks questions about where
you are on an income scale.
So it asks you to put
yourself on an income scale
between one to 10, it's
on an earlier slide.
I think it's one to 10,
it could be zero to 10.
It asks you to put your
parent on that scale,
and it asks you to put your
child on that scale too.
So it's anticipations
of the social mobility
of your children.
We could look at, do you
expect your children to be
higher up this income scale than you are?
And so, it's Latinobarometro,
so it's not a panel, it's
a repeated cross section.
So we're interested in,
this individual I's response
to this income question in municipality.
M at time T, we don't have
individual fixed effects
'cause it's not a panel,
but we can put municipality
fixed effects in,
and we can look again at
aggregate counter-narcotics aids.
And I'm sorry,
that's not what we're gonna do at all.
We're going to look at...
We should chase a notation there.
DT is not counter-narcotics
aid, forget that.
We're looking at the consequences now.
So DT is a dummy,
which just switches on
when Evo wins the 2005
presidential election.
So now we're trying to
look at the consequences
of this for indigenous people.
So capital I, IMT is
self-reported ethnicity
in the Latinobarometro,
so that's the dummy one, if the person
reports being indigenous.
So we're interested in whether,
when Evo comes to power,
you see differential social
mobility of indigenous people.
And what's the answer?
Well, here's the answer for you.
This is your own reported income.
So when Evo comes to power,
comparing before and after what you see
and indigenous and non-indigenous people,
you see a significant increase
in people's reported income.
I don't know if there's a social mobility,
but this is an expected social mobility.
That's the significant, and
much, much larger quantitatively
increase in your expectations,
the expectations of
indigenous people about
where their children are
gonna be on this scale.
And there's an interesting
placebo here you can do,
which is we have
questions on your parents.
So there's no way that
Evo coming into power
could affect where your parents were,
most likely seems plausible.
And then we don't find anything on that.
So that's nice because
it's like a placebo,
it makes the other
results more believable.
It's not that everything is moving.
I'm euphoric, so I'm
overestimating everything.
No, nothing happens with parents, but,
and I guess this is what we
think is most interesting.
Then you see increased
expectations of indigenous people
when Evo comes to power
of social mobility,
measured in this way.
Then the final exercise
before I shut up is to say,
and remind you what the big picture is,
so we have 6 million records of the names
that people gave to their children.
So what we're not able to do
is link parents to children.
So in some sense, the ideal
regression we'd like to run is,
if I took the name of
a child and we could...
What we did was we classified
using a standard list in Bolivia.
Was this an indigenous name
or was it a Spanish name?
And we'd like to capture,
we'd like to measure,
was child I in municipality in time T,
did that child get an indigenous name?
And we'd like to know whether
their family was indigenous,
and then we'd like to look
at the interaction between.
But we can't do that
because we can't link.
So we don't know the identity.
We have these records of naming,
but we don't have the identity,
or the name of the parent. Okay?
So what we have to do is
something much less nice,
which is, we do have the
names of all these children.
So what we're gonna do is we average them
at the level of the municipality.
We don't know who their parents were,
but from the census, we
can recover estimates
of number of indigenous
people at the municipality.
So this is coming from the census.
So the left-hand side is coming from this
6 million observations
of children's names.
The right-hand side is
coming from the census,
but it's at the municipality
level, unfortunately,
and then we can interact
that with this dummy
of Evo coming to power, we can control
the time effects and
municipality fixed effects.
And here's a picture, which is very nice.
So you can see there's no pre trends here.
When Evo comes to power in 2005,
what you see is a systematic
increase in people.
Subject to this, we don't
really have the micro data
that we'd like, but
subject to that caveat,
there seems to be something going on here
in terms of a much larger
proportion of people,
indigenous people start
naming their children
with indigenous names and as I said,
that's what the regression
looks like and quantitatively.
We don't have 6 million
observations here because
we're operating at this
municipality level, unfortunately.
So we had to average.
And quantitatively it's
very large, as I said,
so we can do this as just
looking at the fraction
and this is the total number of children
with indigenous names
and quantitatively the
effect is very large.
The treatment effect is
about 75% of the mean
in terms of the fraction
of children that have
indigenous names to start with.
There's more stuff here, but let me...
This is just like placebos
and just thinking about it.
Let me try to wrap up here.
So when I started, I talked about,
and said why I think this is interesting,
there's this hegemonic narrative
of Latin American developments
or comparative development
within the Americas and
I think it's not wrong.
I think Melissa's results for example,
I believe the results,
but I think what this experience
in Bolivia shows is that,
this equilibrium is
actually a lot more fragile
than it appears when you
read this literature,
that once you start thinking
and understanding a bit about
the kind of architecture of
the state in Latin America,
large parts of Bolivia,
were not really controlled
by Personio elites.
They were controlled by
indigenous institutions
and indigenous society by
the Ayllu and the Marka
and with very little hegemonic control
from LaPaz or anywhere else.
And that's true in Columbia, it's true
in all sorts of parts of Latin America,
so that equilibrium can be perturbed
in very interesting ways.
And that's exactly what
happened in this one instance.
We're looking at a very
specific perturbation
in that equilibrium, a kind of policy that
enormously disrupted the
worldview or the values,
if you like, of indigenous society
and led to this very
powerful, political reaction
that captured the state and
led to good things, I think.
More inclusive things,
indigenous empowerment,
empowerment of women, also,
we don't really have results on that here,
but if you've been in Bolivia,
women are very empowered in
interesting ways in Bolivia,
in traditional society
and today in the markets
in El Alto and everywhere else.
So I think the reason I
like this paper is that
there's a silver lining to the clouds,
to the Latin American clouds, it seems.
And where there's one silver
lining, there may be more.
Just to finish by talking
about Melissa's paper again,
the ironic thing is that a
lot of this action is actually
happening in exactly
these Mit'a areas where
she studied, and in
fact, Francisco Toledo,
who was the man who laid out the Mit'a,
who was the viceroy who laid out the Mit'a
and set up that catchment area.
One thing he did was to abolish
all restrictions on coca growing,
so there's an interesting
connection to the Mit'a
and Francisco Toledo.
So let me shut up now,
I'm happy to answer questions
about the econometrics
if people want to go back to that
or answer questions about anything.
- Thanks very much, Jim.
So we do have some
time, so just open it up
and maybe you could use
the hand raise feature
if you'd like, or just
unmute yourself and speak.
And if there's multiple questions,
then we'll start using
the hand raise feature.
- [Sanjeeev] I have a question.
So do we know what was the
source of increase in income?
It seems like in these areas
were also doing better.
Was it because of nationalization
of mining that happened
in Bolivia and it seems, do
we know the reason for that?
Was it a transfer from
the government to the...
- Yeah, the survey doesn't reveal that.
The survey just asks, it
asks you to place yourself,
for example, on this scale between zero...
I think there are other
questions about occupations.
So not the anticipated
occupation of your children,
but it might be, we might
be able to look at that.
The data that we have, or we've been using
doesn't directly speak to that.
The reason that I like
these naming regressions,
the bat more than the
social mobility questions
is you could say, well,
when Evo came to power,
maybe there's patronage.
There's patronage for
indigenous people or something.
So it could be that,
it's easier to get a job in the government
if you're an indigenous
person, so that could be...
I guess you could say that
could potentially be driving
these results on income
so maybe that's a
mechanism you had in mind.
So that's not the
interpretation that we like.
So I think that that's why
the naming results are better,
but we could dig more on that,
but off the top of my
head, I can't really say
too much about that.
- [Sanjeev] Also the area where
MAS is getting good support,
is also an area that overlaps
with the lithium production.
And that is a big issue in
Bolivia, in the Southwest area.
- Yeah, I don't know much
about the organization
of these mining economies
or how that money
is redistributed.
I don't know if that's
very capital intensive,
what's creating employment
or the rents accrued
to the state and the
state is redistributing.
We have these time effects here.
This is a differential
effect, the indigenous people.
I don't think a boom, in Bolivia,
as a consequence of say,
mineral natural resource prices
can really be driving these
results, I guess I would say.
- [Sanjeev] Okay, thank you.
- Jim, I have a question if I may.
So the paper is really interesting.
And as it's interesting,
all these issues about how
societies in Latin America
have been shaping up and how...
Where the excess inequality
or the large inequality
that Latin America come from.
I really liked all the nuances
that you pointed out too,
and how the colonial history
and evolution, all that.
It's also a very important
moment to look at the stakes.
If you look at what was
happening in Latin America
before the pandemic in Chile and Colombia,
with the social unrest,
that many link to the
absence of community power,
community organizations where
citizens could feel represented.
So all that is nice, it's interesting.
What I'm left a little bit hesitant
on embracing your conclusions is fine,
this is what happened in Bolivia,
where the indigenous
background is very strong
and very prevalent.
In most of Latin America, you cannot think
of something similar happening.
One way to interpret what you're saying,
and I particularly liked
the regressions where,
the results where the coca
suitability is important,
but it's not the story.
The very story is to be inside
or outside that structure,
they argue but, can you
think of other situations
in Latin America where
this community level
empowerment could take place?
Because I have a very hard time too.
At least for the countries
that I know best,
which are, Chile, Columbia,
and to an extent, Mexico,
(indistinct) in Mexico that
might be something like this.
- I think that's right.
I think you're right, in some sense.
I would say the reason that
this took this very interesting
and much more inclusive form
is because you have this very
cohesive indigenous society.
And that's not true in rural Columbia.
It's true in little pockets
of Narino or whatever it is
or Putumayo, but generally speaking,
it's not true in rural Columbia.
But I guess I would say,
I think the broader point
that this literature
emphasize the hegemonic control of elites
and there's actually all these spaces for
alternative political projects to emerge
and flourish, I think that's true.
If you think about Peronism,
thinking about the
history of the Peronism,
that was exactly that.
The Descamisados, who
were the Descamisados?
They were people from the interior.
They were people from the
interior who mobilized,
who went to support...
Again, you might think, well,
that turned out to be a disaster,
but I don't have a theorem about
when political mobilization
turns into something.
That may well be very conditional
on the nature of these
traditional Bolivian institutions.
I agree with that.
- What your story then
could be read is to say,
the situation in Latin
America is characterized
by these big holes that
can be filled by something.
- That's the story in the United States.
Isn't Jackson Turner's
thesis about the frontier,
all about how, it's the
frontier that creates,
the cake creates the society.
It was a U.S frontier
with frontier expansion
and social mobility and
democracy and whatever it was
that actually created
the U.S, not the core.
So I think, trying to
think more about the...
I agree with you, it's specific to the...
Maybe you can think about this
in Peru or a few other places
or Guatemala or whatever, but I agree.
Like many of these mechanisms
are gonna be different
in different contexts and rural Columbia
is very different from rural Bolivia.
But I think the bigger
image I try to project
at the start, I find interesting,
but whether you seek validity
of any of these things,
no, it's very conditional
on these institutions
but I think, that's why I'm
not an economist anymore.
- Can I ask a question about
the global mobilization
of indigenous people?
I believe there's 47
indigenous peoples in the land.
I noticed last week at the UN Food Summit,
that the indigenous peoples
were part of the lobby for zero hunger.
And my other question is this,
within the Catholic
church, there was a Pope,
John Paul II, as a saint, who
told United nations in 1995
in New York at the general assembly,
in this century, we need to have
a universal right for nations.
Do you take this whole
global indigenous movement
has a place in the United
Nations under the banner
of universal right of nations?
Can they be considered
nations without sovereignty?
That's my point.
- Oh gosh.
I don't think my findings speak
to any of those questions.
They're important questions.
I'm not sure I have anything terribly
sophisticated to say about them.
Sometimes during the colonial period,
this Republica De Indios was...
It did have a form of
sovereignty or independence.
The way the colonial state operated,
it granted enormous autonomy
to these communities
to self-organize and that's
true all over the world.
How you recognize that
today in the modern world,
I don't know.
Obviously that's happening a lot,
like there's all of these
people, at least in Bolivia,
and in Chile now, there's a
very interesting discussion
in this constitutional assembly about
indigenous people's
rights and in Colombia,
after the 1991 constitution,
indigenous people
got rights to their land, they
got mandated representation
in national political institutions.
They were recognized for the first time,
but that's not on the same
scale as it is in Bolivia
because indigenous people in Columbia,
maybe 5% of the population.
So I don't know, I'm not
sure I'm enough of a scholar
to be able to answer those questions.
I think you see indigenous
people everywhere,
gaining much more
recognition in Australia.
Look at what's happening in Canada.
In New Zealand, just this week,
the Maori people are petitioning to change
the name of the country
back to its original name
away from New Zealand.
So I think you see that
empowerment of indigenous people
everywhere and that cultural
flourishing of indigenous people.
I think what you're suggesting is
there's a much bigger picture here,
which this research that
I'm doing is sitting in
this much bigger picture and
perhaps that helps explain,
why it was that the MAS were able to grow
and become empowered like this because,
it's very complicated because they also...
Morales is vice-president for example.
He was a Marxist
sociologists so they also,
they tapped into this anti neo-liberal,
anti-Washington consensus
narrative as well.
But it's an interesting question to ask,
and I'd have to go and look
at maybe at the qualitative
sources on this, is to what
extent were they able to
tap into these broader narratives
of indigenous empowerment
in a way that helped them
to grow and flourish?
I'm not sure I know the answer to that
off the top of my head
- Thank you for an interesting answer.
- I see that Daniel and
Gerard had their hands up.
So Daniel do you want to go first?
- [Dainel] Sure.
My internet is a little unstable,
so I hope you can hear me okay.
I had a quick question
about the interpretation
of the moral economy as
explaining the results.
And because Bolivia's
main coca growing regions,
the Chapare and Yungas, are not
necessarily the same
places with the strongest
historical strength of the Ayllus.
So I wondered if you
interpreted the moral economy
as happening equally in both,
the main coca growing areas,
as well as the Ayllus,
which I guess you could say
the main coca consuming places,
or is there maybe a little
more nuance between those two?
Thanks so much.
- I think that the results
that we liked the best
are the ones with the Ayllu
because I think, sure.
The main coca growing areas,
are exactly where you described,
but people are consuming
the coca everywhere.
And it's embodied in
people's lives everywhere.
And so I think that's why I like
these results with the Ayllu best.
You could say, why is it
that in the Chapare valley
the coca layer has got organized?
Well, their livelihood was
threatened, economically.
So that's part of the story.
There's different things going on.
We're not saying this is the
only thing that's going on.
Probably the economic consequences
of having your crops cut down.
There's other evidence on that.
It was important in
stimulating this organization
of the coca growers and whatever,
but I think the Ayllu results is that
you find this effect where
it's not coca suitable.
They're not growing coca, but
they using coca intensively,
because it's so much part of their lives
and their culture and their value system.
So I think that is
about the moral economy,
but there's other things going on also,
which as you say, if
you're maybe in the Yunga,
when we do find these results with coca...
Places which are Coca
suitable outside the Ayllu,
there's also some causal effect there.
For the usual econometric reasons,
we're not actually using coca production.
We could do that but you
we're using the suitability
because it seems to be more exogenous,
but perhaps we should
just check what happens.
We could check what happens
when you look at actual production.
I don't know, did I answer that?
- [Daniel] Yeah, you did.
And yeah, I was wondering
about the actual coca
production zones, but I
understand the concerns,
but it does sound like an
interesting check, thanks.
- Gerard, go ahead.
- Hi Jim.
Just one quick question.
I was thinking about your
results and Melissa's results,
pulling them one side-by-side.
And I guess Melissa has this
story that has always struck me
as a little bit strange
about the haciendas
actually being good,
because they are outside
of the Mit'a and they are
a good thing, basically.
And I suspect, presumably,
places with Ayllus
don't have haciendas at
least formally recognized.
If the Ayllu is defined as
commoner land ownership.
So I wonder (indistinct)
the effect could come from the Ayllus
or come from the absence
of haciendas in a way?
Anyway, I wonder how you
think about this, right?
Especially because there's a
lot more related to your idea,
but the elites don't get
their way all the time, right?
So if the elites are the ones
sitting on the haciendas,
and this is happening in this land where
they actually don't
have that much purchase.
Anyway, I guess I'm thinking about
the other side of the even
if, that you're running.
- Yeah.
I think that's a complicated issue.
And the reason it's complicated
is the 1952 Bolivian Revolution.
So in the revolution,
after the revolution,
a lot of haciendas got expropriated,
and Ayllus who'd lost land
in the late 19th century.
So then in the late 19th
century and Bolivia,
there's a very typical
Latin American story
of expansion of export crop production.
Encroachment on, I don't
know how this works
in Melissa's context, actually
I'd never thought about it,
but encroachment on
traditional indigenous lands.
And then after 1952,
they claimed this back.
So we've tried to find maps of this,
but failed to actually...
I think what you're
suggesting would be extremely
interesting to look at,
this interface between,
but rural Bolivia today,
there's more or less, no haciendas left.
They all were expropriated in 1952,
and this land was reclaimed
by this traditional community.
So there's a interruption
in the first half of the
20th century for sure.
That would be an interesting
source of variation,
perhaps in how cohesive
these communities are,
like a source of heterogeneity, I think.
But we were not able to really find a map
or some documentation that
would allow us to say,
here's an Ayllu which really...
Here's an Ayllu which really
was an enormous continuity,
and here's a place
where they lost the land
in the 19th century, and
then it was restored,
after this hacienda was expropriated.
And if you go round rural
Bolivia you find these abandoned
haciendas and things like that,
or you find a hacienda with
just a little garden around it
or whatever that lost everything.
But we haven't been able
to do that systematically,
but now you're suggesting that.
We did have a long discussion
about that at some point,
but it didn't come to a
conclusion because we tried
to find data and we didn't succeed.
But I think, here, the
story, in some sense,
Melissas's story is, this income
or this development gradient
is caused by good things
happening where the haciendas
are because haciendas
have political power to bring public goods
and investment from the central state.
- Roads and connection
to the market, et cetera.
That's basically the..
There's also a section on location,
which I find more difficult
to explain with haciendas,
but connection to the market
seems like a natural one.
Maybe this thing is just not relevant
by the end of the 20th
century anymore, I don't know.
My gut reaction would
be, it's not relevant,
but Pablo would know
more about that than me.
And we should think more about it.
We should think more about that for sure.
- Because we're running out of time,
let me take one last
question from the Lucienne
and then we'll wrap up.
- You're on mute.
- Thank you.
So I can't remember if
the coca suitability is
varying over time in your equation.
So I am saying that
because there is this paper
from Paula Juliano and
Niteno that showed that,
ethnic group in places with
high climatic stability,
they tend to keep their
tradition and their culture.
So at least for your
result on indigenous name,
I'm wondering if the coca suitability
is not varying over time,
if it does pick the effect of
climatic stability instead.
So I don't know what you
have to say about that.
- Yeah.
The coca suitability is time invariant.
So we have this FAO data on rainfall
and humidity and things like that.
So that's a time invariant
characteristic of this grid cell.
I know that paper you're talking about,
but I'd have to think about how it related
to what we're talking about.
You could say, if I thought
about the long durae in Bolivia,
maybe indigenous, that I would say,
it could be that there's
indigenous culture,
persists differentially,
in some parts of Bolivia
because of the mechanisms that
Nathan and Paula are talking about.
Like I was talking with Gerrard,
we had this idea that if we
knew where these haciendas were,
which were then expropriated,
that would actually give
us a source of variation
in how cohesive these
indigenous communities are.
Perhaps what you're suggesting,
is that's another source of variation.
If we knew something about
climatic variability,
that would actually
create a prediction that,
in some places, because
of climatic variability,
that either the indigenous
communities were more cohesive
and there should be a differential effect.
So that's an interesting idea.
I hadn't thought about that.
One of the most interesting
things about these Bolivian
communities is this so-called
archipelago organization.
That because you have these,
I'm trying to think if this as related,
but because you were in the Altiplano,
but you want crops which grow
in more tropical regions.
So what they did was they would send out
settlements of people so one
settlement would actually...
One Ayllu, would often
have little settlements
down the mountain side,
growing chili peppers,
or growing avocados or
something like that,
which didn't grow up in the Altiplano.
And so they'd engage in this
enormous system of reciprocity.
So they settled everywhere again.
So that's actually, I don't know,
maybe that's something
that could change a lot
if climate changed or something like that,
maybe that's less viable
or it's something,
which you could say
modern spread of markets
also could change a lot.
We thought about that, but again,
where you get data on that,
that's very hard to understand.
It's very difficult to get
data on that or measure it
in a consistent way.
I think that's an interesting
source of variation,
but I haven't thought about it.
I have no guesses as to what
the answer would be, yeah.
- So Jim, along the same
lines, have there been any
significant changes in the
technology of coca production
that interacts with the
growing conditions in any way?
Like makes them less relevant
or more relevant over time?
- I think that's certainly true.
The story in Columbia is that
when Pablo Escobar and
the Medellin drug cartel,
they used to buy all the
coca in Bolivia and Peru,
but then they decided they just
start growing it in Columbia.
But the type of coca strains
that grew in Bolivia,
they wanted to grow it
at much lower altitudes
in the Yanos, the tropical
plains in the east,
and the stuff in Chapare,
it was too high altitude.
So it was too hot, basically,
where the Columbians...
So then they did all this
Jeanette green engine.
It was a green revolution in coca.
They hired these scientists
and basically bred coca that flourished.
I don't know what but that's
the story that's in books
about the Medellin drug cartel.
I don't quite know what
the evidence for that is,
but people tell that story in Columbia.
So that would suggest
that maybe there's some
sort of mutability in these conditions,
but I don't quite know.
We could dig more into the side.
The FAO, that's not
the way the information
is presented in the FAO data.
Is that a budgerigar on your shoulder?
- Yeah.
- Okay, sorry.
It was putting me off.
So I don't know.
- That makes it even more surprising,
the persistent effects of the immutable
portion of the conditions, right?
- Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if that's
happened in Bolivia.
We should ask about that.
I'm sure there's people
who would know in Bolivia,
if that were true and I don't know.
Pablo might know, but
we could ask about that.
- Okay, well, we're out of time.
I want to let people go if they need to.
But Jim, thanks so much
for spending time with us.
And it was great to have you
because it also unsurprisingly
brings together people
from different disciplines
and departments at Yale.
- Okay.
Yeah, I'm very sorry I
couldn't be there in person.
That would have been very fun, yeah.
- All right and thanks everyone.
And thanks Theresa for
organizing as usual.
- Thank you.
- [Ahmed] Okay.
- Nice to see everyone.
Thank you for coming.